a short time from now house minority
leader kevin mccarthy and
a dozen other house republicans are
going to visit a migrant facility
in texas and of course this is amid the
escalating crisis
at our southern border meanwhile the
biden white house is deploying
emergency officials from fema to help
with the surge of unaccompanied minors
despite the president's denying that
there's a crisis well no
fema goes where there are disasters so
we've actually ratcheted this up now
u.s border patrol reportedly is holding
more than 4 200 migrant children
in short-term facilities nearly 3 000 of
them held
longer than the 72 hours legally allowed
house speaker nancy pelosi is blaming
former president trump's policies for
the situation
and echoing biden and calling it a
challenge not a crisis
what the administration has inherited is
a broken system
at the border and they are working to
correct that in the children's interest
so this again is
a transition for what was wrong before
uh to what is right
however louisiana senator bill cassidy
says president biden's so-called open
borders policies
are to blame for the unprecedented
levels of migrants crossing over
empirically it is entirely you can't
help but notice that the administration
changes and there's a surge
and so when people think they can get in
they begin sending their unaccompanied
child
on a train ride across mexico where she
may be kidnapped and trafficked
on the hope that they're going to be
waived through at the border
this policy is leading to this surge
that is unmistakable
you're watching outnumbered i'm harris
faulkner here today my co-host emily
compagno host of kennedy on fox business
kennedy former governor of new mexico
susana martinez
and in the virtual center seat today
larry elder syndicated radio host and
executive producer
of the documentary uncle tom also an
author and attorney
larry i'm going to start with you we
really have taken this up a peg now in
terms of how this administration is
responding
fema goes in for hurricanes tornadoes
fema
going to the border where some
facilities are at 700 percent or above
capacity for little ones
being held and you say what
well doesn't the word fema the the
acronym fema have the word
emergency in it so by definition this is
an emergency even though the
administration
is calling it a challenge not a crisis
look there's no question that joe biden
sent signals to
people in central america that there's a
new sheriff in town
everything is going to be different
there was even a migrant interview not
long ago
and he said that joe biden has given us
peremiso to get here within 100 days and
at that point he's going to allow us in
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
believe that if you send people
signs that that the borders are going to
be poorest they're going to take
advantage of it and that's exactly
what's going on right now
governor martinez new mexico i'm curious
to get your take on how
the administration is responding where
there's so many children now i don't
know if you caught it last hour
congressman
chip roy telling me down at the border
of carrizo
springs texas that there are so many
children
some of them testing positive for covet
19 and crammed conditions as we relax
things to let more people in
and we can't handle it all and they're
crammed into these
little containers but they're not
allowing anyone
any of the american people to see
exactly the conditions in which they're
being held
i think that there should be the vision
of what exactly is happening and not
just
numbers and being told that they're
crammed in you know we have these kiddos
there are 4 200
that have come through 3 000 that are
being held
beyond the 72 hours that is permissible
biden clearly gave bermiso which means
permission
for them to come to the border he said
that um he made it clear
and then if it's followed up by people
in those countries
than saying hey president biden has said
welcome come
come one come all and that includes
these unaccompanied children
now i'll tell you if a child is left
behind
can't keep up walking then they're left
behind
that's inhumane they're not getting paid
to be successful in their travel
they're getting paid to be taken to that
on that route but not
to be successful boy you took it to a
visceral level right there
you did you punched i think everybody
right in the heart i know for myself
governor when you talk about if a child
gets left behind if they can't keep up
it makes me want to cry kennedy why is
the president doing this
the president is doing this uh i i
honestly don't know i i guess it's to
appease part of his base
but apparently that base doesn't like
common sense
or policy and i want to go back to
something that nancy pelosi said the
house speaker she said this is a
transition to what is right
this is very wrong and this shouldn't be
a part of a transition and you know
they're they're sitting there
parsing words and trying to figure out
should we call it a challenge should we
call it an issue we can't call it a
crisis
but what they're not thinking about are
as the governor pointed out
these children who are making this very
very dangerous journey how many of us
could truly make that journey and we
don't know what it
is involved and there's no way of
counting
how many children started and how many
children make it and once they get there
they're sleeping on floors they don't
see sunlight many have said they haven't
slept
uh or sorry showered in seven days
that is that is inhumane i mean that is
beyond a crisis
and if if this is the transition god i
hate to see where we land because it's
only getting worse and worse and worse
well look i mean when you hear nancy
pelosi and others say that this is
something that
biden inherited from trump they have
seen spikes across
presidencies for years that that's not
news but how you respond to it
is whether it works or it it doesn't
work and
my goodness at this rate what will the
next person inherit because they've
taken this way north
of where anybody thought we'd be i want
to get to representative chip roy i
mentioned him
he's down on the border uh and he had
this response
last hour watch there's one thing that
changed in the last couple of months and
it was the incoming by the
administration this is all direct result
of a wide open borders policy by the
binding administration
failure to finish the fence but most
importantly they're basically turning
dhs into a welcome mat
emily while simultaneously
thinning the resources that are going to
dhs so they're essentially hamstringing
them at the same time
another thing that struck me about that
interview harris was that afterward
the congressman said i'm going to meet
with border patrol we're going to get
more information
more statistics and then what what
happens when he then transfers that
information
up the chain when clearly it's falling
on deaf ears
i think what is equally if not more
disturbing
about the sprint versus marathon
approach by people like speaker pelosi
is that we as citizens are supposed to
believe that their decades worth of
service
brings a heightened perspective brings a
heightened skill
skill set of diplomacy of dealing with
this of managing it so that we can have
trust and faith in them
but when we hear from them this again
sprint versus marathon approach
ao this is a new administration we
inherited this without acknowledging
that the issues
plaguing these south american and
central american countries have lasted
decades
that those leaders are simply sitting
back and waiting out administrations
that have tightened border policies for
the next one
the control cartels have all again with
reducing this
to inflicted targeted pain on these
children which by the way are under
more lacks rules more inhumane rules
than we apply to our federal
incarceration system
a shower every seven days no sunlight
that absolutely shocks the conscious so
if they don't want to take that
messaging of a crisis to heart
the rest of us will larry i want to hear
from you one last time before we go to
commercial
well jay johnson obama's secretary of
homeland security said
anytime there were more than a thousand
apprehensions he was going to have a bad
day
this is way way way more than that and
remember
but for the fact that eventually illegal
aliens turned citizens
turned voters would likely vote
democrats i don't believe that we would
have this conversation at all